with opening day bringing back festively
dressed fans peanuts everybody
and a hint of spring baseball is testing
new rules designed to make games shorter
faster paced and more exciting I think
it would be fun to try and grow a bigger
audience speeding up the game adding
more runs more hits will only allow more
people to be interested and view at a
quicker Pace the 30 teams of Major
League Baseball are carrying out an
experiment they hope will save the
American Pastime from boredom pitchers
will have to start their motions in 15
seconds with no one on base and 20 with
a man on when you go to a baseball game
you're gonna you're gonna feel that the
pitcher has the ball he throws the ball
and it's going to increase the intensity
of the game bases are getting bigger
both to make stealing easier and to
avoid collisions and fielders will have
to stay in position so they can no
longer crowd the field where a batter is
expected to hit game has to be faster
we're looking we're already seeing times
being reduced by 20 minutes we're
getting under the three hour mark which
I think is very important ever since
Babe Ruth made his famous called shot in
1932 pointing to center field before
batting a pitch over the fence at that
very spot baseball has been increasingly
focused on the home run in recent years
batters have dawdled positioning for
that perfect home run swing pitchers
took their time game time stretched on
for three hours or more and fans found
it tedious at least some of them did you
think it was getting a little boring
never never baseball's never boring Cubs
baseball never boring it was here at
Wrigley Field that Babe Ruth made his
famous called shot against the Cubs with
the Cubs now opening against the
Milwaukee Brewers fans are showing a
measure of that excitement and the hope
that now games will be more thrilling
than they've been in decades
the Die Hard fans will always keep
coming
baseball's organizers hope that changed
rules will bring new fans to the game
John hendron Al Jazeera Chicago